so
if we're thinking about
aristotle on these virtues devices
since we've you know been gone for a
week let's do a little bit of refreshing
the virtue is going to be a mean in
between two vices in general
virtues and vices are both habitual
dispositions they're the things that
become fixed in our character they're
not there to begin with
maybe the beginnings of them are the
seeds of them are so some of you
were naturally more
courageous
some of you were more naturally a little
bit more fearful or reckless
but over time that can be changed right
you can take somebody
who is full of fear and with proper
training you can make them become
courageous you can also take somebody
who has good
instincts and good impulses and you can
screw them up can't you you give them
bad models and get them to do the wrong
thing over and over again
same thing with you know temperance
which has to do with with
physical pleasures primarily
if you
give somebody if you take somebody who's
been well raised and has some good
limits
and then you put them in situations over
and over and over again where you're
telling them that it's the good thing to
do to indulge themselves as much as they
possibly want what's going to be the
result over time
are they going to stick to those limits
i think
we make movies about this don't we
and songs too you know how one person
ruins another person
sometimes it's actually done
deliberately
you know somebody will
dislike somebody's
good
virtuous disposition and they try to
they try to ruin it you may have seen
that right people doing that
sometimes it's just the environment that
they're in
um oftentimes we don't realize that in
aristotle wanted to stress us our
choices make us who we are
it's by doing things a certain way over
and over and over again that we become
virtuous or we slide into one vice or
the other place
and with some of these vices and some of
these virtues
one of the vices may be closer to the
virtue than the other one is like
cowardice
cowardice is further away from from
courage as is foolhardiness
some of the ones that we're going to
look at in this class session
it's a little bit different
so
one of the virtues that aristotle talks
about
he calls it liberality
and
that's how it's often translated
in part because it comes from the word
for
being free the liberal arts
you know are the arts of a
free person they make you more free in
studying them they free your mind they
make you they
help you to develop
i would say a better word for this
for today
is probably generosity
because this virtue has to do with what
you
do what use you make
of wealth
possessions money um
primarily although we could think of
other ways in which somebody is
is liberal or generous as well but
primarily possessions
um
and and money
so
what do we do with
with possessions and money
what do you do with your money
you save all yours
but eventually you're going to do
something
i spent it else
like food and
gas has been a big thing lately so yeah
even bigger
yeah money
money is there to be we hopefully you do
save some money you don't have a
negative savings rate you don't have to
be any further in debt but eventually
you want to have it so you can spend it
right
and what are you doing you're giving
money
and you're getting things in return
right that's that's pretty much how it
works
you hand them the dollar bill
they give you the pack of gum you can't
buy much for a dollar these days
um
when i was a kid i remember
i remember when gum was a quarter and
every candy bar was a quarter and it had
gone up to that
you know
and so if you had a quarter you could
actually like make out okay
uh now what are you gonna do with the
quarter
i feel like one of the one figurine the
gums like went up from like 25 cents to
35 cents because that was like the worst
time ever for me when i was a little kid
actually
yeah yeah when i was a little kid yeah
because me and my buddies used to go to
the gas station and like you know you'd
have a quarter so you get a pack of gum
yeah remember how pissed off it was that
day
understandably so um money affects our
lives actually a lot of
a lot of my views about how things how
much things want to cost are
unfortunately fixed back around 19
80 81 82 83 so every time i have to buy
milk i'm irritated because of how much
it costs
it's stupid because
you know everything costs more i get
paid more than i would have back then
you know back then
making ten thousand and twenty thousand
dollars a year was pretty good money now
that would be like poverty
wouldn't it
so money is pretty important to us we
have we have feelings about money
um
we
are interested
not just in saving it and spending it
but we're also interested in how it
connects us to each other
this is where the generosity comes in
you can you can give money or give
possessions or give the things that
money can buy
to friends you can think about this in
terms not just of actually physically
giving them something but say inviting
somebody out for for drinks or having
them over for
for dinner
or paying for going to the movies all
those sorts of things
and you can also take right
and some people give more than they take
and other people take more than they get
would you say that's the case
is it right in some cases that some
people take more than they get
do you think
generally we condemn people who take
more than they can but there's probably
some cases where that's the right thing
to do
it'd be kind of weird if your parents
had you know when you were six years old
said all right
everybody's going to do their fair share
now i'm putting food on the table i
expect you to do exactly the same you
would be you know you better be putting
in just as much to this household as i
am and if i take you out to the movies
i'm going to expect something in return
where are you going
i would say
like in a family situation where it's
like one
one part of the family is rather wealthy
versus there's another part where like a
single parent like struggling to get by
for their children and
you're just trying to split the assets
like when like a parent dies or
something and
that like the other family is wealthy
and like
they don't really need the money whereas
the single mother would like
i think that would be an instance where
yeah now i think that might
that one might fit in
if it's an inheritance that would
probably fit in more with um
what we're going to look at next class
of justice how you divide up things if
it was in terms let's say it's a living
parent and
the parents got five kids one of the
kids is a multi-millionaire
got his or her own business doing great
you know
and then a chain goes all the way
through the spectrum down to somebody
who's really hard on their luck they've
had medical problems they've got
three kids single parent
anything else you want to saddle them
with
terrible neighbors
that's probably enough right and so they
give more
they spend more
on them they maybe buy the kids clothes
take them out every so often that they
don't do anything for this this relative
over here and then they can say hey um
this person is more needy this
kid of mine
and their kids
i should give to them more they it's
okay for them to take more than for you
to take more i think yeah that makes
sense
there's probably other
circumstances we can think of as well
now
for the most part if you think about
friendships say or
business relationships the kinds of
relationships that you have already
developed and you're going to be
developing many more of those
or you know maybe think about romantic
relationships like you know who pays for
dates
who pays for trips or things like that
you can think about
giving and taking of money wealth of
property and possessions
and
the the generous person is somebody who
gives when they want to give
who takes when they ought to take
to the right amount
to the right people as well
there's there's all these different
qualifications that come with that what
if somebody doesn't want to give and
they just want to take
one thing that
the translators have used for that
is
meanness
we might also talk about somebody being
stingy being a tight wad
any other terms that you can think of in
our contemporary impressions
frugal
i don't know maybe it's on the other end
of this yeah when we say that somebody
is frugal we're not usually describing
advice we're usually describing
somebody
we're saying that somebody um
holds back the right amount okay
misunderstood
okay greedy
well aristotle's translators will often
translate
the opposite of justice injustice is the
kind of greediness of wanting to take
more in there for sure but i think
sometimes people are greedy and they
don't want to give up things they just
want to take from other people
okay selfish
we often contrast that to generosity
cheap yeah okay
the person who
says they'll take you out to dinner and
then they look at you
aren't you gonna leave the tip
that's a little cheap don't you think
you're gonna take somebody out to dinner
probably or you know they'll take you
out let me take em for drinks and then
you get there and they buy the first
round they say all right
come on
it's your turn
i thought you're taking me out
oh no no we're
we're going out together so everyone
gets you know has to buy a file
i guess that would be cheap
what would be the
opposite aristotle calls this
prodigality
there's other words for this
being a
spendthrift
the kind of people that are always
spending they're always
buying the meals they're always
exhausting their their income their
their property for for other people
we have any other names for that i mean
sometimes we confuse that with
generosity
until the money runs out and everyone
leaves that person right
any other terms that we use
you think of celebrities some
celebrities once they make some money
they just go hog wild
and gifts for everybody
driven name for that in our culture i
don't know
aerosol is very interesting whether we
have names for
for virtues and vices because if we
don't have something we can pin it on
very often we have a hard time
identifying
our ordinary lives
so let's let's look at this
you can
take too much
and not give enough
you can not take enough and give too
much or you can have this this balance
of giving to the right amount
and also taking to the regular homes
but it's not just the amount it's not
like aerosol is just talking about money
management you know like he's dave
ramsey
or somebody like that actually dave
ramsey if any of you ever listened to
the show
he actually incorporates without ever
mentioning it quite a lot of the things
we've been talking about with virtues
and vices
and thinking about what's the point of
having these sorts of things
aristotle says that the the liberal
person
gives wealth to others through spending
on them through giving it away
to the right amount to the right people
that's also important
that's one way to tell the difference
between
a person who is vicious when it comes to
this and a person who's virtuous
who should you give to
what do you think yeah
people who really know those are two
different classes aren't they people who
really need it
people who appreciate it
because some people really need it you
give it to them they don't appreciate it
many of them do
people who are genuinely needy and are
conscious of them
what about people who are say
professionally needy who are
always needy because they blow through
whatever you give them
are they the right people to give to you
maybe not
maybe we should be selective in our
charity or maybe we should think about
who's more needy right should i give to
this charity over here
to help out people who
might be able to get by or should i give
to this charity over here to help people
who are just totally destitute maybe i
should give to that charity
you know
people who appreciate it
i think that
a lot of times
we get guilted into giving to people
regardless of whether they appreciate it
aristotle thinks that
if you're getting a gift you want to be
appreciative you're getting charity
you ought to be thankful that somebody's
uh giving that and you know maybe
somebody who's just expecting it maybe
they're not the right people to give to
you know
somebody who expects everybody else to
foot the bill maybe they're not as
deserving as somebody who actually does
say oh that you know i
i didn't know you were going to help me
out
i'm really glad you did i'll find some
way to try to make it up you know or to
help somebody else out
at the right times when are the right
times to give do you think
are there are there better times than
others
for tax season
if you're just being prudent i suppose
yeah
well i i guess we're using the word need
but it really would be like at times of
need when somebody actually needs the
money to you know
get their basically basic necessities
out of life that they require if you see
somebody struggling to get those that
would be the right time to get it
yeah i think
that would be a clear case of the right
time
i think it's for me because
my mom's a disabled parent
like
as i get older i understand more like
how hard it is yeah
it makes me feel like i want to help her
out financially financially
that's interesting
so like the more conscious you become of
what what somebody else's situation it's
like sometimes i try to
i offer to spend my my money other than
just
yeah and that's probably a very mature
thing to do and
i haven't thought about this before but
if we're thinking about
parents and children
it makes sense for a child
to
have more spent on them than for them to
be giving back to the parents
while they're still a child
part of the the maturation process
is recognizing hey i've got some i i
should pick up some of the
the slack and if you have a parent who's
you know
having a hard time maybe you should
actually spend more
than they do
towards the end of your life towards the
end of their lives
this may be an issue as well maybe
that's how you
give back
at a certain point
that's not just about need though i mean
this is very good that you guys are
talking about that
aristotle thinks that
generosity is part of what holds society
together holds relationships together
um
i don't know what it's like out here in
new york but i suspect there's something
sort of like this
do you
you guys know about this sort of
tradition of giving
sort of impromptu bonuses to certain
people at christmas time
there's like bonuses that people get
because of the place that they work
but
part of part of the thing that my family
would do is
um sometime before christmas
you actually go out there and when the
postman comes by you slip on the 20.
or when the garbage man comes by on on
the right you give him a 20.
or you know
sometimes they give him a bottle of
winter you know back in the old days
now
did they have to do that
was that was a silly thing to do
it was part of how you showed
appreciation for that person's
service and it probably also you know
it's a prudent thing to do because then
they remember you and they think i'm not
gonna leave this guy's garbage all over
the place i'm gonna make sure this guy's
the letters actually get through but i
don't think that my family saw it just
in terms of him
buying a service by giving an extra tip
i think they saw it as this is what you
do
this is how you show
generosity to these people that are
often unappreciated
do you guys do it is that something
that's done on here
yeah
um i actually saw it this weekend my dad
delivered one of the papers in the
morning back at home
and
there's some of his customers that
like will never tip him holiday is
nothing but his older customers like tip
him like through the room older than
like
older people or other people yeah okay
so um
when i was in the papers with him like i
had to walk the paper all the way up to
the front porch and like put it in the
door and like he does certain things for
certain people because
like they've gone above and beyond show
appreciation for him yeah
and notice too if if we try to reduce
this just to
a financial transaction something gets
left out right
something of the human element something
of our feelings about it
just as a just as much as if you tried
to reduce
your relationship to you and and your
parents to a purely financial
transaction you'd be an awful lot left
out too right but that doesn't mean that
the finances don't don't matter
aristotle also talks about the the
liberal person or the generous person as
taking off
through acquisition at the right times
for the right things in the right ways
for the right reason so they're not
going to make their money
or they're not going to accept
opportunities or gifts or stuff like
that just willy-nilly they will actually
be someone
um
somewhat
i would say not exclusive but
they'll exercise they'll exercise some
discretion in doing that
they
also desire
it's not just about reaction they desire
giving and taking to the right amount
so
if we want to contrast it for example
with giving
the
prodigal person the spencer the person
who blows through the money that they
have
maybe their income or inheritance or
whatever
um
they desire to give too much
that may sound a little strange doesn't
it because oftentimes you can never give
enough
give until it hurts right
aristotle thinks that no you actually
should have
a certain you know desire to give
because oftentimes if you desire to give
too much your desire is too strong to
give it maybe masking something else
maybe you're giving
but really what you want is not the act
of giving which is what the generous
person wants but for people to think
that you're you're an important person
maybe sometimes appreciation itself can
become
something that people become almost
addicted to
they want to give so that other people
will say oh thank you thank you thank
you they can't hear that enough
or they want to have control sometimes
people give
in part because that allows them to
run the show
i think a lot of weddings may end up
falling into this category because who
usually has to pay for it i mean
traditionally
a lot of people pay for their own
weddings um traditionally who's supposed
to pay for the most of the way
all
right
the bride's fan right
this is the rice family like cousins and
uncles and their bride's
mom and dad
and that means they get to have control
over certain things doesn't it quite
often
you guys probably know a lot of people
getting married
it's very stressful getting married
going through all that planning and
stuff
why is it so stressful well you have to
deal with caterers and you know cakes
and everything costs an awful lot but
a lot of people want to get their their
hands in people get very emotionally
invested in this and especially
who do you think it's the most
emotionally invested essentially with
the bride
yeah
yeah
very
common that the mother of the bride who
is quite often
putting up most of the money because
what it traditionally what does the
groom's family pay for
yeah um
i know like my best friend's parents are
paying for their sons like the open bar
the flowers like the dj
that's actually good i mean they're
paying for the flowers which is usually
on the bride's family side too yeah the
bar the music
sometimes the rehearsal dinner
um they want to be really generous i
guess they could like throw in a
honeymoon you know
although that's usually left to the
bride and group of people isn't it
um
well sometimes people are just
generously giving hey there's no strings
attached sometimes
they're giving and they're willing to
give an awful lot but they want things
in return they want to get to call the
shots
that's not the same thing as generosity
some people do this you know outside of
weddings with many other things they're
willing to buy
the drinks for everybody in the bar but
then they want everybody in the bar to
see things their way
that would be an example of
aristotle let's say a vicious
disposition
uh the liberal person uses wealth for
the sake as he says of noble ends for
for the sake of doing good things things
that we look up to so helping out
somebody in need would be an example of
that
um
would you think maybe say
funding somebody else's college
education could be a noble end
take yourself out of the pictures i'm
sure all of you would love to have
somebody just you know come up to you
and say
um
you guys are already gone through
college more or less i'll pay for all of
your graduate education or anywhere you
want to go
because i i believe in you
i think this is an investment in the
future in our community
that would be a pretty nice thing
wouldn't it
you'd probably like that
if somebody else were to do that with
somebody else who is deserving you'd
call it a noble end wouldn't you
could throwing a party be a noble one
maybe
some cases
what if it was to
what it was to celebrate somebody's
10-year sobriety you're gonna put your
liquor at the party right because
that would probably be a bad idea
um
and
you shelled out the 200 bucks to
rent a room and provide all the stuff
would that be a generous action would
that be for a noble then
i think so generating you know
celebrating somebody's genuine
accomplishment
probably
weddings are quite often
i think most people are pretty
overpriced but
do they serve some sort of noble head
maybe
some of the weddings you've been to
what what what's actually made up you
got a uh
two people getting married but there's
more to it than that right that's isn't
that why we shell out so much money and
there's all the fancy clothes
or is it just all for show
what else could be the
besides kids
sometimes on the way out actually before
they even get married
what else is one of the results of that
yeah well i would say that the parents
of both the bride and the groom would
feel kind of like accomplished kind of
like part of their job
is done because as a parent you would
want your child to get married and start
to have the family
so i feel like the parents themselves
would feel like oh hey i got this done
it's kind of like a symbol of that
action being completed accomplishing the
function of a parent
yeah maybe um
there there's probably other that's a
good idea there's probably other analog
style
when your parents see you graduate
they probably should have some of that
sense of
at least you know instead of just like
they made it this should be
uh
yeah this is not just it's not just
their day
it's also
it's also our day because
we helped our kid get through
college
i was thinking about you know how you
bring two families together
they often say you're not just marrying
your spouse you're marrying your
spouse's
family
that could be good or that could be bad
depending on who your house and family
are right
for a variety of reasons but you know
shelling out the money for that could in
fact
that could be a noble action bringing
together two communities
into a larger community that could be a
good end couldn't it
um
again if we want to contrast the um
the vicious person with the virtuous
person like aristotle says the vicious
the vicious person not only desires
giving and spending wealth too much they
use wealth for the sake of non-noble
lens like say showing off
or controlling other people
or
distracting other people from something
maybe
filling a
hole in their life that's only satisfied
by
by spending you could probably put
shopaholics over here too they're
they're not being ostentious in the
sense of buying for a lot of other
people but there are people who you know
they get addicted to shopping right
we have tv shows about this
and they spend too much in part because
they really enjoy going out there and
buying things
now one of the things that he also says
is the virtuous person actually pays
attention they do money management they
pay attention to
how they're doing they don't actually
spend more than they're taking in
the
vicious person will often live beyond
their means
and then they find themselves what
happens to you if you live beyond beyond
what are some other results you go broke
and then
what do you do once you go broke
you might shift all the way over to the
other side or you might might resort to
doing bad things to get that money
so he talks about
um
well this is actually going over here he
talks about some people who
end
up doing illegal things
to get one yeah
what's uh what would you say aristotle's
views on
helping people who did just what he said
they
they weren't smart with their money
and
they didn't say they decided to spend
their money and now they're collecting
like welfare hypothetically or they're
asking people for money yeah how there
is that compared to the person that
actually did save their money
you know they were making the same type
of income they said they didn't go out
and buy that flat screen tv like yeah
you did you know
one of the one of the biggest things
with that right now is the housing
issues just
five years ago it was very easy to get a
mortgage
and the reason it was so easy was
because
we'd adopted some policies
really if you if you didn't start dating
antoine both the republicans and the
democrats are not equally responsible
you can pick up particular people
um like you know
dot for example dodd had a big hand in
why the housing crisis went the way it
did uh he was the same guy to make the
regulations his supposed to fix it it's
ironic yeah and and there were people
who were on both sides who were being
lobbied by fannie mae and trademark
um and and what was going on is it was
made very very easy to to get access to
money to buy
housing
and the idea was housing is just going
to go up and up and up and up
if you know anything about economics
you and about the history of economics
you know that doesn't work that people
are always
anytime something is the hot investment
it's probably being inflated and sooner
or later it's gonna the bubble's gonna
pop and go down but the reason why
there's a bubble is because there's all
these people out there at that time
thinking hey i can't go wrong about
investing in this
so you had a ton of people
making foolish investments buying beyond
their means thinking i'm gonna sell this
house in two years and make a profit
then suddenly
we started having these financial crises
and it took place in a lot of different
ways and eventually hit the housing
market
housing prices dropped and that's still
going on in this area
some of the housing some of the housing
in here probably hasn't hit rock bottom
yet
in
this particular local area
there's a lot of foreclosed houses up
for sale right now
because the banks people couldn't make
their payments
and the banks you know
foreclose on them and then they have to
sell the house
um
should we help those people that that
could be one of the questions that you
ask
and i remember listening to a talk show
i was talking about this in
chicago at that time i was still living
in northwestern indiana
he was a man
he was saying you know
when i got my mortgage i researched it
inside and out and i made sure that i
actually had enough money for the down
payment and that was within my means and
my income
and now we're going to bail out all
these people well and he said you know
basically screw me but you know the word
that he used
he didn't use that radio but it was
bleeped out because he was so angry
and i think part of that is that
indignation about well if somebody gets
themselves in trouble should we should
we fail them
and aristotle would probably say maybe
some of the prodigal people
need to learn
a harsh lesson so i think aristotle
would be receptive to that
it could still be
generous in some cases to give to them
let's say they're your uh
your kid
maybe the government should
pay for them maybe you should help them
out if you can
it's
it's
again with this question we start
getting into issues of justice as well
so i'm going to put that off until
next week
let's go over and look at this now the
the stingy person they give wealth to
others less than they should or perhaps
not at all they're they're taking but
they're not given
and we see that as a bad character trait
don't we
um do any of you like having friends
like that
you're going to stay your friends
forever
friends they actually should be there
should be some reciprocity there right
um
unfortunately if you have family like
that you know you can pick your friends
you can't pick your family right they're
not going to quit being your family if
they're
particularly stingy
they often take wealth more than they
should for the wrong reasons or in the
wrong ways that would be the greedy
people that are taking more than their
fair share
aristotle talks about those who as he
says ply sorted trades that means those
people who are
um
engaged in occupations that are kind of
of unsavory the occupations that may be
illegal or maybe they're not illegal but
they're
they're certainly not good forms of
occupation where they're taking
advantage of people they're
you know think think of for example
i'm not i'm not tarring all collection
agents in this because there are some
collections agents who are
you know decent people other virtues and
stuff like that but there is something
about collections
that
sort of leads itself to
um
especially if you're the one who's
collecting for yourself
if you buy contracts
to collect on people's debts
there's a tendency to bring out the
worst in us in that isn't there
would all of us be able to resist that
temptation to
be abusive towards people to threaten
you know all sorts of things that aren't
really going to happen to them to
squeeze a bit more money out of them
maybe not
and why you know why would somebody get
into that in the first place
they want money it's a great way to make
a lot of money
there's certain things that you could do
for money that would
probably be damaging to your character
they often
don't neglect their own property but
they they manage wealth just for one
reason which is to have wealth
the generous person manages wealth
remember back when we were thinking
about the purposes of life the generous
person recognizes the goodness of wealth
and they try to you know
manage it well so that they have it to
give
the stingy person
wants to keep the wealth they see the
wealth as just a good in itself
now
aristotle also talks about another set
of virtues and vices
if we look at this in a large scale
in ancient greek society in the
city-states that people lived in
if you were rich you were expected to
shell out
for public events or public benefits in
some way or another you're also expected
to take care of your friends family
you know do that sort of thing
do we have stuff like that in our
society
aristotle called this
magnificent literally doing great things
so if you were an ancient greek
and all of you were rich people maybe
you would actually buy a trireme for the
the navy and staff it with with men
maybe you would actually
hire the the playwright and the chorus
for putting on a play
maybe you would put up
um the money to actually start a new
temple to
zeus or whoever we want right um
maybe
you would actually you know let's say
you're you know quite so much money but
you put on nice parties you know where
people come together and they
get to mingle and you know we have these
events right
maybe you would put up the money to
fund an artist to create great
sculptures that would be in the city
square you know
those would be examples of magnificence
of doing great things for one's
community
not just private giving but you might
call it
public public spending
do we have stuff like that in our
society
we have a lot of things like that right
do we call them magnificent
do we have any terms that we use
for people who are we might say good
donors
charity
um we might call them charitable
maybe we don't have a word for good
plan
yeah i
yeah you know
a lot of these um
a lot of these big uh
tycoons and robber barons and
manufacturers
from the 19th century
ended up doing a lot of good in our
society
by building things like libraries for
example
andrew carnegie
who was apparently a pretty tough
businessman but a lot of people out of
business
ended up
building all these libraries all across
all states
did he do good by that
did he contribute to communities
i think so
i think he probably made huge
contributions that he wasn't even aware
of at the time
um that would be a true philanthropist
now he may have gotten his money in you
know ways that are less than savory
but certainly after he had his money he
knew what to do yeah doesn't intent like
have a lot to do with it like i know
like the rockefellers uh intentionally
said yeah
because they actually
i forgot what exactly happened but they
hired they were one of the first like
businesses or so called to hire a pr
person
and they hired this person and then he
would give them advice on as to what to
do with their money to better their
image as like not so evil people yeah
and that's how we have like the
rockefeller center and whatnot because
of this guy's suggestion
okay
yeah
yeah i suppose if you were just doing it
for pr reasons then arizona would say
that's
the vice which he calls vulgarity
we might call something like that just
purely self-serving giving
or
whitewashing you know somebody's image
nowadays we actually have this term
green washing right these companies give
lots of money to environmental causes so
nobody will look at the pollution that
they're doing you know they call that
green washing
they have solar panels
they must be good people if they have
solar panels
well not necessarily
what would be at the other end
aristotle the translators call it
stinginess
um i don't know do we have words for
people who are wealthy in our society
and want to be giving something they
want to be doing some sort of public
service or
some sort of donation creating something
something for the community but they
don't do we have any any terms that you
can think of
nothing comes to mind for me but maybe
you guys can think of
a good term maybe the fact that we don't
have a term is a problem
you know
maybe we let rich people off the hook
too yeah she's like well foreigners
okay
you could always make a bro
we could but
you could yeah you can always make up
your own word you can always change the
meaning of getting other people to
accept your word and to use this thing
i can say we're going to call this blue
from now on but you know
none of you are going to accept that to
begin with even if you did we don't only
have our own little private language
until it caught on
now what's going on with these people
they they don't want to give
or if they do give
they give too little
um
they they sometimes do spend
but they try to spend less than the
right amount
so somebody who is willing to you know
somebody gets pressured into well we
gotta give something you know we gotta
go to the gala well we're gonna go to
the gala and we're not gonna buy
anything uh we're gonna just enjoy the
band and all that we're not gonna put
any anything into the silent auction
right these are the sort of things that
rich people can do
as a matter of fact there's all sorts of
events all the time
that
most of us just don't have the money to
go through
and a lot of those events do a lot of
good for our communities
i'm not saying that we should not
be necessarily envious about them
because a lot of them collect money for
good causes and
end up building buildings all these
buildings that you have on campus for
marist
the ones that all have names on them
unless there's somebody like you know
fontaine
he didn't put up the money for this all
but some of these other halls somebody
actually came up with the money for that
or at least the seed money to get it
going
um scholarships
were often named after people aren't
they
those are either the people who created
the scholarship or
they're somebody that that person wanted
to memorialize that somebody who died
and who they wanted
to
pass on the memory of by creating a
scholarship
um the stingy person doesn't want to
spend they spend less than the right
amount
oftentimes they will ruin the good
effect that they create by their
stinginess by cutting corners
by
showing that they aren't really
interested in giving without attaching
all sorts of strings to it they focus on
the costs aristotle says and how to do
things more cheaply rather than on
what's beautiful or fitting
so if we contrast that back now to the
virtuous person the virtuous person
focuses on
not the cost
but on the the object what is it that
they're trying to achieve
so when they're funding a scholarship
for example
you know if somebody let's say you're
you're on a full scholarship you're
going to go to graduate school somewhere
and somebody puts up a full scholarship
in your name
what should they be caring about
should they be
saying no you're not going to use it for
this are you
i only want to spend this amount
or should they care about
what's going on with you what should
that scholarship achieve
it lets you go to school that's just the
start of them right
what's supposed to be happening to you
as you go to school broadening your
future or like
making you more successful because of it
yeah and that's a future consequence
hopefully
what's supposed to be happening in the
present that leads to that
whenever you actually
do have some real learning taking place
you grow as a person
i think you have all experienced this
quite a lot in your majors you've grown
as a person you're not the same man or
woman who walked in here two and a half
years ago are you
you are in some ways bigger
not physically
but also maybe physically and still keep
growing right but in who you are in your
soul
you are a larger
person there's more of you
you've grown
the person who's giving money for a
scholarship should be concerned with
that
what about the person over here what are
they concerned with they're not going to
count the costs
but they're interested in making a big
show
like he says
aristotle says they're interested in
making a big show rather than on the
real beautiful or befitting product
they often are
lacking in good taste
they can't see what would be good in the
circumstances what the good taste would
require
why do they actually
want to spend on a large scale they want
to show off their wealth they want to be
a big shot
they want other people to look up to
them to think that they're they're
successful that they're suffering
the generous person the magnificent
person the philanthropist is not really
that concerned with what other people
think of them
they're more concerned with the good
that can be achieved through
spending that money
and now all of these are habitual
dispositions all of these are things
that people
will do
when you give them the opportunity and
will show their character you can count
if the person really is vulgar you can
count on them to be vulgar the next time
around the next time they're out if a
person really is stingy
you can expect them to be stingy not
just in this case when you go to ask
them for a donation but the next time
and if a person really is
a philanthropist for a good word for it
or magnificent
you can and this is what actually does
happen you can't hit them up multiple
times
for good causes
and they will distinguish between good
causes and frivolous crosses
you know um
let's think for an example about you
know really
easy to relate to thing you guys have
that tunnel that goes under the
highway nine
and you guys have been here long enough
to remember what that tunnel wasn't here
has that tunnel improved your lives
yeah those of you who live on campus
now does
the tunnel's pretty utilitarian looking
is it really glowy inside
i haven't actually been in there but i
can see from the outside
what if they put
mosaic murals
wouldn't that make it a better
experience for you each time that you
walk through
you know
maybe marist could you know spend some
money on buying some famous artwork
like it could not only be a tunnel
but also an art gallery
maybe a picasso should be in there
what do you think
that would just be you know that'd be
silly wouldn't it
it's not an art gallery
it's a tunnel that serves a purpose it
does a good thing it improves your lives
but it's just a tunnel
you know
why would somebody want to you know
spend that much money on adding a bunch
of bells and whistles or trills to it
well if somebody does that's because
they spent money on frivolous causes
because they want to make a big show you
know
the actual
magnificent person is not going to spend
on that sort of thing they're going to
look at the projects that they commit
themselves to once they commit
themselves they're going to be committed
they will be an advocate for that
maybe some of you
actually i hope you know
i'd love if all of you could actually
end up becoming
magnificent people that way because it
would actually mean that all of you are
extraordinarily successful
even if you're not you can at least be a
generous person
let's look at another
virtue now aristotle says there are
virtues that have to do with social life
so those virtues have to do with what
with money with wealth um but they also
had to do with personal relationships
didn't they
or at least relationships in your
community there's others that have to do
with how we relate to each other in
society and one of these that he talks
about is what he calls
truthfulness
now he doesn't mean honesty in the sense
that you guys are brought up many times
in the semester as soon as i ask you
about what's equality that you want on a
friend you always say honesty
what do you mean by it you mean
something a little bit broader than what
he's calling truthfulness
because you mean somebody who's honest
about everything right
you ask them did you take my bike
yeah i took the bike
where's my car
oh i had to take it to uh to the store
it's still in the parking lot they don't
lie to you about that sort of thing
aristotle is not talking about that per
se
he says that he's this is dealing with
truthfulness and falsehood in words and
actions
and self-assessment about one's own good
qualities or achievements
and this is a lot of stuff that's still
a wide range right because
all of us present ourselves in a certain
way all of us
talk about ourselves don't we
who doesn't like to hear other people
talk about them
honestly you know we all like to hear
other people talk about us to some if
they're saying nice things right
um
as a matter of fact you guys now are at
the stage where
several times you've already had to put
together documents that tell who you are
right
y'all have a resume
do you ever have the the
temptation to spin the resume a little
bit
maybe fluff you know one one part or
inflate you know something that you did
into something a little bit bigger
there could be a lot of motives for that
maybe you just you know like thinking of
yourself that way or you're afraid that
you're not gonna get the job if you
don't do that or everybody else is doing
that and so you have to do it
or somebody else pressured you to do it
well that wouldn't be truthfulness about
who you are would it
in a way that would be what he calls
pulsefulness which is
inflating your good qualities
or your good achievements or your
attributes
and then
he talks about what gets translated as
self-deprecation
i think that another term that we could
use for this is
putting oneself down
aren't there some people who do
habitually
downplay their own good qualities
or attributes
they don't take compliments well
you give them a compliment real
confident that you know there is
something really good about them whether
you really accomplish
something that's a lasting benefit or
you know
was really well done and they say oh no
they find the one thing that they didn't
do right in it
this is a really good paper yeah but i
misspelled can't on page three
they're kind of missing the point aren't
they
yeah we're gonna say oh no i'm sorry i
don't know
okay
um
so truthfulness about oneself
truthfulness about oneself is being
honest
about
what your qualities actually are
you know how good are they in actuality
they might be you know
this good but not this good
they're still good right
they're good in some way they're good to
some extent
and about one's achievements
bless you
so the truthful person only claims good
qualities or achievements for themselves
which they actually possess what does
the boastful person do the boastful
person sometimes just makes stuff up
you ever run across somebody like that
makes stuff up they
never actually were in this place but
you're having a conversation about it so
they got to tell you about their
vacation that they took there that was
better than your vacation
you all see that right
or um
it's really easy to do this about stuff
where there's no possibility of getting
caught
by the way this is kind of a sideline i
noticed this for the first time
rereading this material yesterday
aristotle actually when he's talking
about boastful
people he says that they will often lay
claim
to qualities that are either seen as
honorable or distinguished
you know things that give a person a
good reputation or they they claim to
things that are beneficial to other
people
um so two different kinds of good the
honorable good the beneficial good you
know the useful good
and the
three groups of people that he singles
out he says also they also tend to pick
you know ones where it's hard to check
up on it's hard to to catch them in
their their line
he says there's three groups of people
that they most often will you know or
three types of
skills that i'll most often lay claim to
one of them is medicine
back then there wasn't an ama there
wasn't any you know medical school or
certifying thing
nowadays would be a lot harder to claim
to be a doctor isn't it
the other two groups that he talks about
are
prophets
those who would you know say what the
gods want
and philosophers
he says that a lot of people pretend to
be philosophers who aren't actually
philosophers why because it's hard to
catch them
and if they really were philosophers it
would be a pretty cool thing
but they're actually not philosophers he
says this in a book of philosophy that a
lot of people are pretending to be
philosophers who actually aren't
imagine if you're reading that and
you're like trying to pretend to be one
out of now i guess
you know he says another thing too when
he's talking about anger he says one of
the things that people who get angry
tend to get angry about is when you
disparage something
that they care about
but they're not as good as they'd like
to think they are in that thing
so if you disparage philosophy to
somebody who's just starting out in
philosophy isn't you know very well
versed and then hasn't done any really
major achievements they'll get more
ticked off than the established
philosopher who's like you can attack
philosophy all you want i don't care
that's going to be what it is i'm secure
in it it's the person who's insecure who
tends to get the most angry and the
person who's insecure is quite often a
poster
somebody who is laying claim to
something that they don't actually
possess
or that they possess in a lesser degree
so
somebody will
have picked up a guitar once in a while
yeah i play guitar i play in bands
i've been playing for 20 years
well you know i've been playing banjo
for
like
12 years
if by playing you mean
maybe
two or three times a month getting it
out and instead of actually practicing
the things that i'm supposed to practice
playing a couple songs that i like
does that make me a great banjo player
what do you think i think you should
bring the banjo to class
but now it doesn't make not
on some available
you know they're somebody who's being
boastful guarantee there's also somebody
who's a great
banjo player or guitar player pick
anything that you want
who downplays their own achievements
who who overlooks it um
now
aristotle actually says this is kind of
interesting
if this person
leans one way or another it's
going to tend to be more towards this
way than towards this way why because
it's felt to be in good taste to down
player your good qualities
what's the what's the desire that's
governing this
he says
this person is actually a lover of truth
he he claims a new term
for her lover of truth fill allah face
you know this person is going to be
truthful even when there's nothing to
gain by being truthful just because they
like to be truthful
and they also find
lies or misrepresentations or deceiving
another person
as in some way
he says painful but i think we would say
something more like
they they find it not disgusting
necessarily but um
what lies some what's what's a sort of
lesser form of
disgust when somebody wants you to do
something and you feel kind of a
repugnance towards it
you've all
gone through that sort of thing
yeah
unbecoming okay yeah it's unbecoming of
them to
to tell even small lies about about
themselves
that's the way the person who's truthful
by disposition
actually is because they value truth and
they
they dislike lying they see lying is a
bad thing in itself
um
the bolster
doesn't see lying as a bad thing or if
they do see lying as a bad thing they
see it as certainly less bad than the
good things that they'll hopefully get
out of it like you know reputation
maybe who knows
access to opportunities wealth those
sorts of things
they value their self-image more than
they value
truth
it's interesting aristotle had this this
saying
he disagreed with his teacher plato and
you know back in that time it wasn't
like today when you tell your teacher
anything you like i think you're full of
it you know back then your teacher was
your master
and he said
we should love our friends but we should
love truth more so we should be willing
to disagree
when truth is at stake
that's not the case for the boaster
some posters actually like to lie there
are some people who
even met something like this
tell lies about themselves
they don't even have any reason for
doing it they just lie to lie have you
ever run across that type
there's something going on there what
about this person over here
aristotle is kind of uh
hedging his bets about this he doesn't
think that everybody who's over here is
necessarily ambitious he says some
people like like socrates for example
avoid showing us
they disclaim you know great attributes
socrates is a pretty smart guy if you
read through more of the philosophical
dialogues that plato wrote you'll you'll
realize this
socrates over and over again pretends
like he doesn't know what's going on
that may frustrate you too
come on just out with it i know what
you're saying here
um why did he do it
does anybody know from
remember back to intro class or
if your teacher talked about that
why would somebody pretend they don't
know something that they actually know
in talking with their friend
yeah maybe potentially not to
make their friends feel stupid or to
make themselves like they don't belong
in that crowd eventually
yeah sometimes we dumb it down so that
we can we can fit in socrates wasn't
doing that
and actually sometimes he if you read
through the dialogues he does make
stupid people look stupid
he shows them up by you know
by
a lot of the stupid people in dialogues
think that they're a lot smarter than
they are
and he lets them sort of fall into their
own traps what were you gonna say um
wants to be right all the time
i know some people who want to be right
all the time
you know some people who want to be
right all the time we don't like them
right
but
yeah maybe there's something kind of uh
unattractive about being right all the
time
so maybe socrates could be hiding his
knowledge for that reason
in part it's it's to yeah go ahead i
know he says that he knows he's smarter
than a lot of people because
um he knows that
he might not be wrong he knows that he's
not always right so he's smarter than a
lot of people he's acknowledging that
you
is getting to what you're talking about
yeah
think
there
as well
yeah and sometimes he's actually kind of
faking that too because sometimes he
talks he doesn't know anything but he
doesn't know some things
um yeah
he just wants to see their honest
opinions before he gets to say is
there's something to that too and and if
somebody
acts like they they know everything
right you're not gonna get other
people's
genuine opinion are you
just giving
so he can teach
if your teachers use the socratic method
they often pretend like they don't know
what they're doing and let's just open
it up for discussion
and hopefully
you know
it'll gradually pull the truth out of
you by leading you into it
but you can't you can't actually come
right out and say i know exactly where
we're going right
that's going to work
and that's what socrates does
and it is very important to be able to
actually draw them out and see what do
they actually think
some other people
fit into this better he says affected
people disown or downplay low value
qualities
or those that they obviously have if
somebody actually does have a good
quality and they tell you no i don't
have this
quite often they're being affected
they're kind of showing off in a
different kind of way
falsely humble people he talks about
make a show of putting themselves down
like the person who tries to show how
poor they are
by wearing
ripped jeans and you know stuff from
goodwill even though they're filthy
wrench
there's something kind of funny about
that isn't there
um or the person he talks about the
spartans the spartans
deliberately adopted
very simple
dress i don't know if you know
many of the stories about them they were
forced to undergo a lot of rigorous
training
and to develop a lot of toughness which
made some of them kind of sociopathic
a violent sociopath is what we probably
call a lot of those departments today
aristotle thought that was kind of
showing off
that wasn't really
you know
they would sort of downplay their
qualities but everyone knew exactly what
they were saying so they would they
would pretend like they were you know
drilling all the time so they could
possibly measure up to being great
warriors they were the toughest warriors
in greece
right
so their self-deprecation
when it becomes
a habit becomes
vicious
and in our day i think if we're going to
translate this into other terms
wouldn't we talk about this as the
person who doesn't take credit for
their good actions they let other people
take all the credit
when they shouldn't and there could be
some cases where
you should let other people take the
credit
like when they actually deserve it yeah
what about people who like
like fish for compliments or like oh man
i'm so fat oh
that's a good
appreciation yeah that's a good question
um
they're definitely not
i didn't even think that that they just
want people to tell them otherwise it's
like they put themselves down so they
could boast about it i don't know yeah i
think i think you're right fishing for
compliments
uh
that would be a type of so i feel like i
know a lot more people like that than
people who put themselves down
for other people to take credit i don't
really know anyone like that but yeah um
you mean people who are like genuinely
humble
like overly humble okay
yeah i guess the fishing for compliments
then would be an example this is a good
example of these ones would be like
guys trying to deal with girls because
you have
that cocky guy you know some of the guy
like searching for pity yeah
nobody ever wants to go out with me
um what else did they say
i can see why women are attracted to
other types
i'm the one who's always the friend
never the boyfriend
and then that turns into a set of lines
you're saying
yeah i think that would be a good
example and then you're right there are
plenty of guys who will go out there and
like you know
talk about their income
who they know
what else do people most about
is there anything people don't post
about it maybe
maybe not that's probably a good place
to close um we didn't get to all the
other virtues that i wanted to get to
but you have um
some
charts for them
that i've created for you
so if we're thinking about
courage
when it comes to any of these
rustotelian virtues and vices
it's often helpful to think of other
words that we use are there any other
words that we use
besides courage
to describe that that sort of character
trait
yeah
yeah we talk about a person being a
brave person having bravery
and remember when we're talking about
virtues and vices we're talking about
something in the person
something that they have
developed that's part of their character
likewise advice devices um
we have uh
with any any virtues and vices we have
for the way aeris level understands that
we have a virtue that's the mean and the
center
so in this case it's going to be
courage or
bravery
and then depending on how you want to
look at it he talks about access and
deficiency not not enough too much
with courage it's a little bit trickier
isn't it because it has to do with two
different things
two different emotions which are
actually opposites to each other it has
to do with what what's the one that
stands out right off the bat
what's the emotion that courage
has most to deal with
fear right but um aristotle talks about
the opposite of fear which is confidence
um
actually other philosophers opposed
other
feelings or passions or emotions to fear
like hope for example but aristotle
talks about confidence
and by that he means the sort of sense
of
being able to do things being able to
succeed
think about the confidence those of you
who are athletes the confidence that you
have after you've drilled you've come
together as a team
you know exactly what you're doing and
you're going up against a weaker team
right you're fairly confident you're not
100 sure
or you know those of you who play
instruments a certain confidence comes
with that those of you who are now who
talked about this before okay with
public speaking who weren't originally
okay with public speaking like 99 of the
population
but now when you get up you actually
feel relatively confident that's that
feeling he's talking about
and you can think of the
cowardly person as
both lacking confidence and having too
much fear right so
should we place them on this side of
deficiency or this side of excess it
doesn't really matter so long as we
understand that there's there's too much
of one thing and not enough of another
so let's just put it over here
cowardice are there any other words that
we use in our culture besides cowardice
calling somebody a coward
we have a lot of sort of slang thing
somebody's a chicken you know remember
the playground
kids you know actually like mime a
chicken to each other
do we have any other terms that we use
aristotle is very attentive to language
it's a moral language
or something
yeah okay that i think that would work
if we wanted to make it a substantive we
instead of calling somebody
uh cowardice comes from
coward we'd have to call it wimpishness
or something like that we'll just put
women right
and we all know what it means
and if you're calling somebody a wimp i
think that you are saying something very
similar to
calling them a coward
any other terms that we use in our yeah
yeah
yeah
we still use that interestingly
um
it's kind of an old-fashioned way of
talking isn't it you know you're seeing
a lot of westerns and they they don't
say yellow they say yeller you're yeller
but
we we still do call people that we have
i think we have a lot of other
vocabulary what about the other extreme
aristotle talks about rashness
or foolhardiness
um
this is the person who has too much
confidence undue confidence
any other terms that we
use in our culture
yeah coffee
okay yeah um
i think that would extend to some of the
same things cocky people
tend to smarter off to other people when
they shouldn't
in situations which
would maybe call for a little bit of
circumspection a little bit of worrying
about the consequences these are people
who don't worry about consequences
maybe that helps out that
you know when you look at that show
jackass for example i think all of you
have seen that show or versions of it
a little while back there was a female
version called rad girls where they're
doing some of the same kind of things
those would be people who would fit into
this
i think
you know they're they're
somehow lacking in something or having
too much of something else that removes
them from the virtuous
meme
so let's think now about what aristotle
actually says about about courage
remember these are
character traits
they're not just character traits like
things that you're born with like some
of you
may have an artistic bent
or
you know you're naturally good at
athletic endeavors
or
you sort of naturally
gravitate to situations where
you can
exercise leadership
or some of you are good at picking up on
other people's emotions
those are character traits right but
they're not necessarily developed you
might have just had those of course if
those of you who are athletes
does it help to actually practice
you know somebody may have some natural
talent
but um
those of you who have artistic you know
talents of one form or another are
studying uh things in the arts
can you rely on raw talent itself
that's one of the problems a lot of high
school kids coming to college i don't
have to learn anything i don't have to
do this technique stuff because my high
school teacher said i have a lot of
talent and i just want to be creative
well you know you have to you have to
refine it you have to work on it through
practice
courage is the same way some of us are
more naturally
closer to this than others
some of us naturally tend to have more
fear some of us naturally tend to be a
bit more foolhardy
the courageous person has developed
a quality of their character through
through exercise
through being in in situations and
you know they deal with the things that
we
are afraid of or or ought to be afraid
and so aristotle with all the virtues
he's going to say
we think about these virtues and we want
to look at the person who actually has
them as a model and we want to think
about
what reason would tell us
so
the courageous person is the person
who has the right amount of fear and the
right amount of confidence
and acts on that right amount of fear
and confidence because it's not just
enough to feel you have to act in a
certain way
and what kind of what kind of actions do
we associate with a courageous person
what do they do with that that fear or
in the face of scary things
what would you say
yeah
let's say someone who's courageous to
someone who has like the right attitude
towards fear so they can like take their
fear and
stay calm rather than like
go
get hysterical and
become kind of
self-indulgent or become a leader
whatever needs to be done in this
situation
okay so that's there's
two things that you're saying that
aristotle says there
one is they remain more or less calm
they don't allow the they feel the fear
but they don't allow that fear to
predominate in their reactions and
you've all seen
you know both of these cases right
you've seen people where you can tell
they're afraid
and they seem in the grips of the fear
and the fear runs out
the fear is in charge not not that with
the courageous person the courageous
person is in charge of their fear
they're feeling it
but they're able to do
things that are not just determined by
the parent and then you said
they're able to do the right thing
they're able to do what needs to be done
that's really central for aristotle the
courageous person
is able to act and to do not just
anything
but think about all the possible
reactions that we have to fear think
about movies when you see the
movie and everything suddenly comes to
the point where things get screwed up
and now everybody's realized that
they're screwed up there's always one
hysteric guy who's yelling and
overreacting and you know then it's like
you know fighting with aliens or or a
bad guy or something like that there's
always somebody who wants to appease
them maybe if we're just nice to them
they'll leave us alone right and then
there's there's a whole range of other
reactions in the middle sometimes people
slap each other
get a hold of yourself
they're encouraging each other to act in
certain ways and not to act in other
ways by doing that
you could do the right thing in the
situation you could also do a lot of
wrong things couldn't you
people sometimes act foolishly out of
fear
to try to get away from it
so
reason would tell us
how we ought to to act
it would also tell us what we ought to
be afraid of and this is a key
difference too
so think about this what are you
actually afraid of
in your life
um
you know your fears have changed over
time right are any of you afraid of the
boogeyman
anymore
maybe you watch too many movies scary
movies you are right
at the time you watch them
but you're not afraid of the things that
used to be afraid of
i i was afraid of a tornado under my bed
when i was three years old
i don't know where i got this idea from
but i thought there was a tornado under
my bed i didn't have a monster you know
tornado i didn't know what it would do
actually and my mom took care of that by
getting the vacuum cleaner and very
obviously sort of vacuuming under the
bed and telling me this story about how
you know tornadoes are a wind and the
vacuum would suck the wind down throw it
out
the bag and then i was okay but you know
i had a lot of other
crazy things like that i bet you did too
some kids get they talk about the easter
bunny and they get scared of the easter
bunny believe it or not
they don't want that bunny coming into
their house like a home invader i
suppose um but you're not afraid of
those sort of things you have you have
more realistic fears
so what are the things that you're
actually
afraid of
as
20 odd year old students
yeah
failure
i think that's probably the biggest one
i mean you guys are not in
danger of losing your lives at any given
moment if you were living in a war zone
you would probably be less worried about
failure and more worried about getting
killed every single day
but
in our society failure is
a big one and i think it's particularly
pressing for your generation
i was just thinking about this with some
of my online students
my generation
we're probably going to work until we
die
because the retirement system is you
know gradually breaking down the economy
is really not improving
um but at least when i got out of
college there were a lot of jobs
for you guys what is what is your
situation like it's rather bleak isn't
it you you have to there are jobs out
there
but you have to compete for them
and one of the possibilities is failure
uh economically
you know not being able to
provide what you'd like to provide for
yourself and then later on for your
family that's
that's something that's staring a lot of
people face
and you guys have seen a lot of a lot of
people who have skills
have
had you know good jobs before
lose them and not be able to recover
right
so that's that's a real fear
i think
what other kinds of failure are you
worried about
any of you worried about how the
semester is going to pan out
i think some
every semester there's things that come
up
what else what else are you worried
about just in this mode of fear what
else are you worried about failing
does anything else come to mind or is it
primarily economic
academic
and if you worry about relationships
you know romantic relationships whether
it's going to succeed or
fall apart
or maybe worried about that in the past
yeah
and you probably will fear that in the
future at the times too because
anytime you put two people together
especially you know if you meet somebody
in your 20s you're going to change over
time and you'll have to either adapt and
harmonize with each other's changes or
failure will take place yeah
i'm not sure if
i think that's um
yeah that's another thing that we fear
and
it could you could actually be in a
situation
where because so many people have
different expectations you can't
possibly meet all of those
and people worry about this you know
fear gnaws away at us doesn't
you know if we don't learn how to manage
it
um it can motivate us to do all sorts of
things
what else are people afraid of so
there's this possibility of failure
which is a that's scary
what else
what about rejection
sometimes even when you do the right
thing
measure up the things somebody treats
you for them they don't like you
i think a lot of people are afraid of
rejection
um
if you want here's here's a little hint
too if you want to get used to rejection
start submitting your stuff to magazines
and journals
for publication because you will get an
awful lot of rejection letters you know
send your writing out
or outfitting your musically client
start sending your music stuff out you
will get a lot of rejection and you'll
either develop a very thick skin
in dealing with that which might be a
kind of courage or actually it might be
a kind of rashness
oriole
you'll quit
you know
what else what else are people afraid of
what are things that most people tend to
be afraid of do you think
we talk about death aristotle talks
about that too
yeah
losing people that you love
yeah not not only your own death
but
those of
other people that you care about
some of you've probably experienced
some deaths already
this is kind of a grim thing to say but
if you think about it every single
person in the world everybody you get
attached to either you're going to die
before they are or and they're gonna
have to grieve you or you're gonna die
or they're gonna die before you and then
you're gonna have to grieve them or
you're both gonna die at the same time
so it's one of those things that we
can't escape and you have to deal with
you've probably all dealt with deaths
too
and you can fear it you can you know
fear is in the future tense you might
say
you can worry about these things that
aren't yet come to pass but you know
we're coming up
my wife doesn't like me to talk because
you know i'm unfairly
matter of fact
we have dogs
dogs don't live forever do they
the dogs are are
seven and eight years old
so
how much more can we really expect maybe
another seven eight years
she doesn't like me to talk about that
because then it raises these
these natural fears that we feel
losing things what else are we afraid of
losing
people
pets
we're afraid of losing our possessions
aristotle talks about the fear of
poverty
fear of losing things that we like
some people can become so attached to a
particular item that they can they can
be very afraid if that item is somehow
threatened
imagine if i were you know a book of
aristotle you know if this is the only
book of aristotle left in the world
then it would probably make a lot of
sense to be afraid you know if i were to
lose this but
this is replaceable
right
people aren't
quite so much this this this is just a
bunch of words on pages you know put in
a nice
binder
but we do get attached to our things
don't we
um
oftentimes we're afraid also how people
see us
aristotle talks about dishonor
we're afraid of being ashamed
as a matter of fact here's where it gets
kind of interesting
one of the things that aristotle says
about cowardice is sometimes cowards
will do things that look kind of brave
like you know they'll risk death
or even you know taking on certain death
but oftentimes they do it because
they're more afraid of the other thing
than death itself they're more afraid of
disgrace they're more afraid of losing a
reputation and they are
dying that's not true courage
so here's the thing
we can ask what are we afraid of and
then we can ask what should we be afraid
of
how much should we be afraid of things
when you feel fear you can ask yourself
is this i know i feel the fear is this
reasonable to be afraid of this thing
is it reasonable to be afraid this much
is it reasonable to allow the fear to
run the show
and if your answers to that are
no
then you probably have some work to do
in order to steer yourself towards
courage right
because if you if you don't ask those
questions and you just sort of go along
with things
and your fears are great you may end up
becoming encountered
i think
a lot of you have experience with
overcoming fears
of various sorts
what are what are some fears that you
guys are voted on besides public
speaking we've already talked a lot
about that
what are some other fears
yeah
and now have you ever seen anybody
that's a good example i think so getting
promoted or getting getting an
opportunity to do something and then
worrying whether you
will be up to it
i think a lot of you have gone through
that haven't you
have you seen people who
who didn't measure up
why didn't they measure up
there's a lot of different possible
reasons right
the stars weren't aligned right you know
things just didn't work out for them
have you ever seen any of them where
they allowed the fear the exact same
fear that you're talking about
to
dominate their thoughts
and to keep them from actually doing the
sort of work that they needed to do
to make good on that opportunity
have you ever seen that happen it's kind
of a little self-fulfilling we talk
about self-fulfilling prophecy where
you're too worried about
how you're going to perform
and that worry itself keeps you from
performing
i don't ring about
i think some of you guys in in athletics
have seen this with people
right somebody gets into a slump with
hitting
or with
what would be the equivalent of lacrosse
what do you actually call them
shoot
shoot shooting somebody gets a slump
with with shooting they can't ever seem
to hit the goal
um
they feel like they they can't possibly
succeed they start to worry about what
everybody's thinking
and pretty soon they're caught in a funk
and they can't get out of it if they
don't watch it that can that can lead to
this vice of cowardice
we talked about bullying is you know
sort of an example of this too
somebody's bullied they don't stand up
to bullies this happens over and over
again they may develop a cowardly
sort of disposition
let's look at the opposite now what
about rashness
should you
face up to every single fear or dismiss
every single fear
aristotle says no there's some things
you actually ought to be afraid of
it's right to feel fear
when somebody
threatens you with a gun
as a matter of fact
if somebody is just putzing around and
playing with a gun and it's loaded you
probably ought to feel afraid if you
don't
you might be over here
that might be a problem aristotle talks
about a couple different ways in which
this can occur one is the person just
doesn't feel fear when they want to feel
fear there are some things
that it's natural it's normal to be
afraid of not afraid in the way the
coward is afraid you know too much but
to to the right extent the way the
virtuous person is
like for instance you know
let's take failure again
it is reasonable
in the
situation that you guys are in
as college students right now
to be afraid of failing
not necessarily failing your classes in
that sense but you know the economic
situation you guys are moving into it's
tough
nobody should candy code that for you i
think
if you were to have the attitude you
know like people had in the 80s you know
the future's so bright i have to wear
shades
that would be very unrealistic wouldn't
it
there are some people who
act like that though
aren't there
i saw a lot of students actually when i
was at my last position
who were coming in with 800 sats
and thinking they were going to be
doctors and lawyers and you know
ceos and things like that and all they
had to do was show up to class didn't
have to do any homework or reading or
anything like that and it was an easy
stream
then just wait out there four years
what's going to happen to that
what do you think
you guys are not those students you guys
are a much uh
more
well-prepared graded students and you
guys put in a lot of work what do you
think is going to happen to those people
who
think they're going to just coast the
whole time
yeah
um
and they'll probably find some way to
you know explain it away
somebody was screwing them over or
something like that but really it's
their own foolhardiness
their own lack of fear when they want to
feel fear it's reasonable to feel some
worry in the economic situation that
we're in i think
another problem is overconfidence
sometimes you feel fear
but you also feel this sense of
confidence and that sort of carries you
through and that can also come from a
very unrealistic assessment of the
situations that you're in
and we'll talk about a few ways in which
people end up being a little bit too
confident in a moment
then he also talks about another really
interesting thing
where some
people who seem to be
rash or
overconfident or
cocky or however you want to put a
really cowards
because what they're most afraid of well
let me ask you
what do you think people like that are
most afraid of
people who are they actually sort of
hollow inside
they um on the exterior they look like
they're really confident
can take on anything yet like people
finding out they're not actually like
that
like that they're actually cowards yeah
it's interesting aristotle is noting
something back in
the 4th century bc that we still see
today
people who
put on a brave front
because they're actually filled with
fear inside and they're so afraid of
other people seeing that they feel fear
for whatever reason
you know whatever consequence would
follow maybe they'd be made fun of maybe
they'll be taken advantage of
maybe they'll be the weak one that gets
attacked
that they have to go overboard and act
like a super brave person
the
the courageous person stands up to fear
they do the right thing they do what
ought to be done in the situation quite
often that may mean
engaging in some sort of conflict
standing up against some sort of danger
and that danger could be other people in
their their attitudes or their
aggressiveness
the rash person
is going too far with that
they stand up against everybody whether
they should or not
the you know the rash person
well let's take this for an example
none of you are our previous military or
have been in you know
police force of any sort or anything
like that right have any of you like
done martial arts to the point where you
are
black belts
no
okay so if somebody comes up to you at
the atm and they hold a knife at your
throat and say give me the money
it would be pretty reasonable for you to
give them the money right
you'd be motivated by fear would you be
a coward for doing that
no
what would the rash person do in a case
like that
try to fight them
right
for for you know whatever reason
maybe they would not feel any fear
maybe they would be overconfident i can
take this guy
he's got a knife
but i've got my fists
my fists are deadly weapons
no
um or maybe they're so afraid one sec
they're so afraid of showing fear that
they would actually like lever
themselves into that yeah
oh
my friend who actually like stood up i'd
say that was that was a courageous act
she dealt with fear in a way that
actually
kept her safe
more or less i mean she was taking some
risk right but the courageous person is
not eliminating risk the courageous
person is standing up to
a risky situation
and she made her position very clear
the courageous person we would say these
days is very good at setting limits
it takes courage to set limits well and
that's part of what she was doing she
was saying look i'll give you the money
because obviously
you're really into having this
but i'm not giving you the credit cards
or the ideas here's why
and then
the guy the guy accepted it
um
so i would say yeah
that's coming from a courageous
disposition one other thing that
aristotle says that's a good question
that brings up another thing aristotle
says
the courageous person
is going to be ready to do this sort of
thing in situations that they haven't
been in before
so this is a good lead-in to how courage
differs from a few other things that
look like courage did you have your hand
up
um
aerosol talks about five things that
resemble courage but are not really
courage
and one of these is
being in the grips of anger
we're going to look at anger next
people who are angry who are
in pain who are frustrated will often
stand up in the face of danger or in the
face of aggression
um
but quite often they won't do it in a
way that's right they'll just stand up
against it and we look at that as being
courageous
but what happens when that emotion of
anger goes away
do they remain
courageous do they remain resolved
think about somebody who let's say
you've got a boss and the boss is a bad
person and the boss is acting abusively
to an employee
and it finally takes somebody off and
they they stand up and they say we're
not going to take this anymore you're an
awful person you shouldn't behave like
this
they're being motivated by this feeling
that they they have right anger or
frustration or
indignation something like that
what happens once that fuel goes away
do they still hold that position
in your experience
what do you think
you can get people to do things that
they ordinarily wouldn't have the
courage to do by provoking them
but that's not going to have the
constancy the staying power of genuine
courage
he also talks about
feeling confidence
because of one's previous achievements
some people are very
courageous seeming in part because
nothing bad has ever happened to them
interestingly aristotle talks about
drunk people as being
temporarily in that state drunk people
feel themselves to be a bit invulnerable
you guys seen this sort of thing
you know the the tiny little guy who
wants to fight the gigantic bouncer you
know who's twice is literally twice his
size like twice his weight and he thinks
that nothing bad can happen to him
because he feels confident
that's not genuine courage they actually
have
an old expression from what they call a
dutch courage i'm not quite sure why
alcohol was associated with the dutch
because they traded or something like
that but they call that dutch courage
it's not real courage because as soon as
the alcohol wears off what happens to
the person
yeah some people will you know take a
drink you see this in a lot of old
movies when they have to listen to some
bad news right why because there's a
sense in which it will give you courage
but it's not real courage is it
um or you don't think about romantic
situations why do people
drink so much at the bars where they're
looking to pick people up or to hook up
because it gives a sense of confidence
right now it doesn't just lower your
inhibitions and also
maybe give somebody a resolve but that's
not real courage
and that's uh you know not going to be
there in the morning
or even later on that night
he also talks about people who are
ignorant of the danger that they're in
that's not real courage either
not knowing you know
if you for example were
think about this economic situation if
you were to say
um
yeah i don't know about any recession
things seem great where i come from
let's say you actually live in an area
where everybody's got a job
the unemployment rate is
2 instead of 10
well
then um
you wouldn't really be courageous
because as soon as somebody informs you
the facts
now suddenly you'd feel some fear
wouldn't you if you're reasonable
or what if you didn't know that the gun
that you were playing with was low
or what if you stood up to some
bullies
but you really thought you were just
play acting
or that everyone was joking around
is that real courage
that's not encouraged we make movies
about that sort of thing right
but the hero
does some amazing things they don't
realize that they're not actually the
real situation
well that's probably enough about about
courage let's move on to think about
temper
what makes you angry
what kind of things
get your goat
what takes you off
yeah
sure that doesn't make sense how many of
you
when people are mean or disagreeable it
makes you angry
especially when they're mean or
disagreeable to you not just to this
poor guy next to you but to you or to
somebody you care about right
aristotle says that makes perfect sense
that that's part of
part of what makes us angry as a matter
of fact the definition that he has in
anger
is
a desire accompanied by pain for
apparent retribution for retribution
setting things right punishing somebody
else making them suffer in return
aroused by an appearance lighting
against oneself or those connected to
unself sliding meaning
treating somebody as less than they
deserve
it's literally
um coming from a word for less holy god
um
the slighting being undeserved when we
get angry we feel like something wrong
has been done to somebody either to
ourselves or to our friends or our
family
our country
some product that we like people will
fight about products our sports team you
know
you shouldn't talk about the bears that
way
tv shows people get very attached to tv
shows
i'm not sure why but we do
and we get angry over these sorts of
things right
some people think you should never get
angry
aristotle says that would actually be
a vice
he calls this interestability
which literally means not being able to
get angry or not getting angry when you
want to
aristotle thinks there's a lot of
occasions where you want to get angry
he's he's different than some other
philosophers
and theologians in this respect
there have been a lot of philosophers
who said anger is always a bad thing
like the stoics for example epictetus
anger is never going to be a good thing
a lot of jewish christian muslim
thinkers anger is not a good thing you
should get rid of it
aristotle will say no you actually
should get angry
but you should get angry
at the right time
for the right reasons
to the right extent
with the right people
all you notice all these different
rights
for the right amount of time there's all
these different qualifications
where do we tend to go wrong
do we usually tend to go wrong and not
getting angry enough
no
we're where do we tend to go wrong
interestingly aristotle doesn't have
just one name for
this vice he actually talks about a
bunch of different
ways in which we know
some people are hot tempered as he says
or we call them hot heads right
if somebody's a hot head they get angry
very quickly don't they
do you know people like this
yeah
the good thing about hot heads though
that aristotle says they get angry very
quickly more quickly than they want to
so they're not in the virtuous mean and
they get angry about things they
probably shouldn't get angry about
but it doesn't last a long time they're
willing to let it dissipate so if they
just walk it off they'll they'll get
over it
that's actually a good trait isn't it
because then there's also the
what he calls the choleric
they are a quick temper they're ready to
be angry with everything and on every
occasion these are the people who
you might think of them
as
grateful when we talk about somebody
being an angry person
oftentimes would mean this they're angry
all the time right do you know any
people like this
yes
no
you're lucky because i think most people
have at least one person like this in
their life somewhere
they don't let that anger go
then there's the
as he calls the sulky
or the hard to appease
we might actually call them the passive
aggressive
or the grudge holders
see when a person is angry what do they
want they want to inflict some sort of
pain or to see pain inflicted
on the person that they're angry with
aristotle says anger is different than
hate hate wants to see the the person
that is being hated just go on
wiped off the face of the earth anger
wants to actually see them there so that
they can be punished
so that they can feel some some pain in
return i think you're all familiar with
this you know
that's part of what makes your anger
so hard to take care of sometimes
because there's no way you can make the
person
feel that they did you the wrong and
that they're being punished for it that
makes you angry again
you know
when they brush it off
you do something in anger to them and
then they don't they don't get hurt the
way that you want them to
the grudge holder will not be satisfied
until
they are able to get that revenge that
they want
and they may take all different ways
of doing it there they're hard to
appease aristotle says they repress
their anger until they can actually take
their revenge
so in some ways we're sort of getting
from
bad to worse to worst
right
and then he talks about the
the the bad temper
literally
i would i would translate this
you know it's a part of my my
vulgarity the pains in the asses he
calls he's the holocaust which means to
make trouble these are the kind of
people
who are
what would be a good word to describe
them
they're hard to get along with
they always have something that they're
getting upset about not necessarily
something huge like the rageful person
who just you know
breaks dishes and swears all the time or
you know things like that storms out of
the house but they always have some
little thing to say
everything that there's always something
people like this probably shouldn't
watch tv because
you've seen them they watch the tv and
they've always got some snide comment to
make try to think of a good word for
this i mean the aristotle's greek words
are hard to translate sometimes we have
these descriptions
how would you how would you
what would you call a person like that
yeah
oh yeah
okay that's good
yeah
we're sour they're sour people right
that's coming from anger
they they're getting angry at things the
racial person will like you know throw
out a soda can through the tv
because they're so so angry out of
proportion
you notice there's a lot of ways to go
wrong with anger
there's there's really one way over here
although i think aristotle would
probably say
if we were to sit him down today
that
there's probably more of this than he
thought
i think he was looking at you know
fourth century
male greek society not at the whole of
society there's probably people who
don't get angry when they want to get
angry
more in our society than just
people who get tuning right so the
person who like it takes a lot for them
to get angry
oh that's a good question
aristotle says the person who has
good temper
is more towards this side than towards
this side
in part because it's so easy to go wrong
and anger and one of the things you
notice
probably you've all you know reflected
on this when you actually get angry it
becomes very difficult to measure
how appropriate your anger is how well
directed it is how long you should you
should be angry
one of the anger management uh textbooks
that i i've read
actually starts off by saying the very
first thing you ought to tell yourself
when you get angry is a stupid person is
now in charge
because your anger makes you less able
to reason out how angry you should get
so if it's going to be an established
character trait it probably needs to be
more on the side of not getting angry
being forgiving being willing to give
people the benefit of the doubt
before you know
exhibiting anger
then towards this side
he says that there people who are
in this position
they are not prone to seek retribution
but to make allowances and to be
forgiving
now you know that that's not to say
they're always going to be forgiving
there's some things that you should get
angry at if somebody
just
no provocation whatsoever attacks your
parents
you should probably get angry
if you don't
you probably don't like your parents or
there's something
something wrong
but you're gonna
sure
that's
that's what he's talking about there
although that might also fit in with
cowardice too
um
if the person
well like he says the person who's in a
basketball doesn't get angry when a
person ought to get angry or at the
people or things that want to make a
person either so they put up with
insults
they put up with being treated badly
he doesn't say this but i think he would
also be willing to say
they put up with getting less than their
fair share of things like maybe
attention time
resources
money that that doesn't
get to them
and it could be in part
i don't think aristotle thought
thought this out when we talk about
somebody being passive aggressive we
usually think of that as a type of anger
there are people who choke their anger
down so much
sometimes because they have to
because you know if they don't they'll
get they'll get beaten up or abused in
other ways
but sometimes because it's a way in
which they
adapt to society in which they you know
take on this quality of niceness that we
often value
and make it into something like advice
they don't stand up for themselves
they don't they literally can't see
after a while when somebody's doing
doing wrong to them or doing wrong to
others so with that does he say like
what who or what's the best way to get
your anger out
oh that's a good question the aristotle
does not
go into that
but that's a very important
thing to think about
he he talks about
being angry in the right way by that he
means acting in the right way with your
anger
but he doesn't tell you what actually
constitutes
being angry in the right way
and i'm willing to bet that some of that
would be
cultural i think we've probably made
advances since aristotle's time
um
except in certain parts of our society
we don't usually resort to beating
people up just you know 40 years ago
there's probably a lot more common
i think it's probably a good thing that
we don't beat each other up as much
what do you think
should we go back to
somebody makes you angry let's beat him
up
no
no that's just because you're not into
beating people up right
or or is it because it's more reasonable
not to not to beat people up and try to
talk things out
what do you think
you don't want to beat people up you
should probably have a good reason
for that
you had something else you can say well
i was just gonna say that people
either take it out on people they don't
know where people they do know and often
times like
yeah they're right like bitter people
will just be like
put their anger towards everyone they
meet but some people like
only do it to like their family or and
don't show it in the outside yeah
you're right
um
or they'll do it to people who are under
them at work or
they'll always have some sort of reason
like
you know
they're my family they have to put up
with me
my friends don't
or
i'm in charge of them i get to do
whatever i want aristotle would say yeah
that's an example of being angry with
the wrong people
you get angry with this person over here
and then take it out on this person
you're at you are aerosol say angry with
this person you're behaving like an
angry person towards that person even
though this is the person who actually
provoked you so that would be that would
be an example of vicious anger as well
let's move on to temperance then
so temperance is a word that we don't
use an awful lot
we've talked about this before we
typically use this when it comes to
alcohol
a better word for it i think is
just moderation
what do you think
because what is he talking about he's
talking about
what we do with our desires for physical
pleasures
although
aristotle wants to really narrow it down
to food drink and sex
myself i would be and i think probably
you'd be willing to recognize that this
could also apply to all sorts of other
physical pleasures and maybe even to
some mental pleasures
like you know
how many of you like to to read and have
a particular genre of book which is your
guilty pleasure
you spend too much time sometimes
reading that
it could be you know for me it's it's uh
science fiction and fantasy it could be
mercenary novels spy novels romance
novels westerns could be books about
comedy
could be books about beekeeping who
knows you know whatever whatever it is
that you're into that's a mental
pleasure right but you could have too
much or too little of it you have
desires for it
and that's how you indulge those
desires think about the pleasant things
that you desire where you indulge
yourself in
we have a lot of different this is a
great society for that right with a lot
of different pleasures we can indulge
ourselves in
what limits should we set on that
well let's think about different
pleasures what are what are some of the
things we find particularly pleasant
yeah
um
well just thinking about like the
like a society of people from belgium
yeah and um
we now
we probably have the greatest plethora
of food choices
ever available at any given time in
history
right now
it's just amazing how
how
you know on the one hand the chef has
become a celebrity and we have all these
foodie people that you know make all
these different things
the food industry is gigantic it offers
you
amazing ranges of tastes when i was a
kid when i was a little kid
bubble gum only came in one flavor
and it was bubble gum flavor right that
was the flavor basically just like sugar
i think
i don't know exactly what made it bubble
gum flavor
and then i remember the revelation when
great bubble gum came out and we were
like wow
you can make bubble gum and it doesn't
have to taste like bubble gum
and then they started coming out with
other things orange flavored bubble cup
root beer flavored bubble gum then they
had you know like bubble gum where it
would have little sparkly things
they got more and more labyrinth
and
now we just sort of take that for
granted yeah
whatever flavor you want for gum
put it in there
you can make gum tastes like garlic if
you want it
you can make it taste like roast beef
um probably somebody who's done that
right
um
passion fruit we didn't even know what
passion fruit was when i was a kid i
remember what a revelation it was for me
i went to a birthday party for the girl
living next door who was just turning
nine so i was ten
it's the first time i ever had tacos
and i didn't even know they existed of
course
we didn't have soft shell tacos back
then that took another couple of years
to make it into our neighborhood
and we had these tacos and you could
make them yourself you don't put the
meat in the meat had a really good
flavor to it and then
their tacos were all one type of variety
then meat
lettuce
tomatoes
and cheese
right that was it
and it was always cheddar cheese it
wasn't you know different types of
cheese and there wasn't any sour cream
or salsa or stuff like that
and
now
you know
tell somebody you're gonna have a taco
what kind of taco what's going to be on
it
tacos are kind of passe aren't they
would anyone flip over a taco
oh you're tacos wow i'm coming over
you know we we live in this this
this
great
surplus of
flavors and taste and all that and you
could easily lose yourself with that
couldn't you
what's your favorite thing to eat
you can only eat one more thing the rest
of your life
it would be a kind of ice cream it would
be a kind of
meat dish or any kind of
i don't know
kind of soup maybe here
yeah they're good
when i was a kid it was only chef
boyardee too you know the original stuff
um unless he lived in an italian right
you know
okay so ravioli now you know
you can
there's the right amount of ravioli to
eat right should you have ravioli every
single diet probably not because it's
kind of a rich food
how many helpings should you have
as many as you like
whenever you like
what will happen to you if you
indulge yourself in that way
i mean physically something will happen
right
you get fat you get overweight
and that comes with certain certain
things
you get sluggish you know when you eat
too much you want to go to sleep which
doesn't help because then it's empty
calories
once you start setting that down as a
habit though what happens
what if you don't get that thing that
you want now how do you feel
yeah
we have um
oversized portions
here in the united states a lot of food
people have been writing about this for
a long time you know
porsche ravioli should probably be
fairly small
um i would like a portion of bradley
only to be big because i'm used to big
portions in parks i grew up in the
midwest and
you know that was a sign of
prosperity
now if you give me a little portion
this is a sign that i'm with myself not
another temperament i mean you look at
me tell them about ten programs of food
right
i get a small portion i'm like i paid
that much for this
this is all i'm getting
ah
this is awful this isn't a meal i'm
gonna have to have another meal after
this so i'm not gonna be hungry well
that's a sign that there's something
wrong
aristotle's likes about this is uh
temperance another word they use is
prodigality
when you think about the the story of
the prodigal son you guys remember that
old bible story
um
he ends up being really poor right and
then he goes back to his father
what happens before that though
what does a guy do yeah he like asked
his father for like his half of like his
inheritance and then he went out and
like
spent time he didn't just gamble
what else is this yeah well like i mean
like like through parties and stuff like
that
just gambling but he spent all of his
money like he didn't
try to invest
yeah he spent it on physical pleasures
yeah i mean it actually says you spend
it among prostitutes
among other things
and then suddenly you know once the gone
all his friends are gone
and
he's left destitute and now he's eating
you know the food that the pigs have
or i was hungering after it
um practicality is is indulgence in
physical
physical pleasures
what about drink i mean you know or
think about
other things that we do to
change our mood to get us
feeling a certain way
um
there could be a right amount
you know aristotle wouldn't counsel not
drinking at all
he actually calls that insensibility
um
some people just aren't attracted to
certain physical pleasures
some people
don't desire
food
some people don't desire
good tasting things drinking doesn't
necessarily have to be alcohol it could
be indulging in coffee it could be
indulging in
tea soda
what are the things that we like to
do that pretty much cover it
i suppose you could you know drink too
much milk if you were really really into
milk but i don't know anybody
like that
um
anybody who
has an unhealthy
obsession with drinking milk probably
people like that
usually they're over here some people
just don't have those sort of desires
that's not a good thing aristotle that's
you actually want to have desires
um
but you ought to set certain limits on
them
what are some other things we have we
have food drink
um can you have sex with anybody you
want to whatever you want to
i mean you know
there's all sorts of rules about that
sort of thing to begin with
would it be good let's say we got rid of
those rules would it be a good good idea
to do that
probably not right
i mean you could think of all sorts of
things from health class
do you remember that would that would
militate against doing that
um
for one thing you'd never get anything
done
but there'd be all sorts of other issues
that could come up as well
um what are other things that feel good
that we can
desire too much that we can indulge
ourselves in too much
what about i mean there's an eight
o'clock class right
how many of you would have liked to laid
in bed a little bit longer this morning
you know it was a cool morning
your blankets were probably warm all
right it feels good to just lay under
the blankets get the snooze alarm i
usually hit this news alarm at least
once how many how many times do you guys
hit the snooze one
how many of you do it once
usually
how many of you do it more than once
why
why do you do that i mean in a way it's
kind of torturing yourself isn't that
snooze alarms are kind of a bad
invention
uh
because
is it really good sleep that you're
getting after you this news alarm goes
on
how do you feel after you you finally
get up a little pressured
a little rushed
that's because you indulged yourself a
little bit isn't it
but it feels good doesn't it
to lay in bed
it's a physical pleasure we feel i mean
animals feel this right the dogs will
like get a blanket and they
dig around in it to make it to the bed
just right for them
there is something here aristotle
doesn't talk about this but we we
encounter that what else do you think
you could have too much of as far as
physical pleasures yeah um well for some
people exercising
like you can either do like too much
yeah once you get past
the
painful part of exercise
exercise can actually become very
pleasurable they talk about the runner's
high
some people actually become addicted to
exercise don't they
why do they become addicted to exercise
it's not just like self-image or
something like that it actually
physically feels good right mostly we're
athletes
in prime condition it feels good to
exercise for you right it doesn't feel
good for me to exercise because i am not
over that hump yet
it used to feel good for me to exercise
and i i actually was far too indulgent
with that believe it or not
back when i was your age
was exercising about three hours a day
which is you know for
the graduates to be a little bit
excessive
um
any other physical pleasures you can
think of that we
maybe indulge ourselves in too much
do we have to set limits on or else we
will
screw things up for ourselves
what about let's say now we start moving
into the things that are more
that involve our mind they're not
necessarily mental pleasures like doing
arithmetic in your head for those of you
who you know indulge yourselves too much
in logic puzzles in your in your head
probably not too many of us right
including myself
what do we spend more time on
devote more attention to
that than we probably should because we
enjoy it
and we find ourselves
sometimes
feeling upset if we can't do it
think about your computer
or your console
game console or
your phone
what are the things that we spend too
much time
on the internet talking to people
yeah social media
they're they're actually worries about
about facebook addiction twitter
addiction in addition to regular plain
old internet addiction
some people get so
obsessed with staying in touch with
everybody through texting that they they
get sleep deprived because they answer
texts at three in the morning this is
becoming a problem for college students
that could become a problem for me i can
tell you that because you know nobody's
texts are that important for me but i
can understand that because
i remember
playing strategy games i enjoy strategy
games and losing hours
hours just you know
going by and then looking at the time
and realizing oh wow i was supposed to
have done some work today
have any of you ever
had that happen maybe not strategy games
maybe
video games of other sorts racing games
you know pro football
who knows
i
on facebook i know that a lot of the
people that i'm friends with at least i
used to know this until i blocked this
stuff like to play bejeweled blitz
and
the scramble type game and all that so
people are spending a lot of time on
these sorts of things
and why are they doing it because they
enjoy it right
nobody's forcing them to do it they're
not getting money out of it
can you do it too much
can it become something that
becomes too strong of a desire that you
indulge yourself in habitually
that you'll feel bad if you're not
getting
yeah
people do do end up doing that
watching television some people can't
live without the television
i suppose music
we talked about certain types of reading
becoming that
with all of these there's there's a
virtuous mean which is which is
temperance
and like aristotle says
how can you tell if somebody really is
temperate
they take pleasure in the temperate
action in the temperate amount so if we
we go back to food
when
if i'm trying to lose weight i'm trying
to move myself away from
intemperance to temperance
and i get the small portion and i eat
the small portion i am doing something
that a temperate person would do
i'm not yet doing it like the tempered
person would do it i'm not doing it with
the same frame of mind as i'm doing it
i'm grumbling while i'm doing it i'm
feeling pain that i'm not getting more
food
all right
when i actually become temperate if that
ever happens i will actually get the
regular sized portion that i ought to
have and said
looks good
this is the right amount for me
yay
perfect
and i won't be craving more afterwards
so you know
i i'm willing to bet that many of us are
not necessarily
way over here you're not totally
at the mercy of your appetites are you
you're functioning college student
if you were i don't think you'd be able
to stay in college
um how many of you think that you're
over here with all the different
possible appetites that you come across
i'd be really surprised if any of you
were at your age i mean i should be by
my age i'm not
but you know i think a lot of us are
actually
more
around here
what do you think
you know some people who are over here
they just don't take pleasure in things
that's not a good thing
the good thing is to actually have
healthy appetites
but to maintain them within certain
limits think about it sort of like
pruning a tree
after you prune the tree enough it will
actually take on the shape that you want
to have
we are out of time so we're not going to
get to
friendliness unfortunately
but i will take that up with the the
other class
and
next class justice